history in the making quite literally
these are the first coins featuring King
Charles III and these 50 pence pieces
also pay a special tribute to his mother
the reverse is a replica of the coin
produced to celebrate her coronation
back in 1953. So anyone under 50 will
only have ever seen Queen Elizabeth II
on the coin so significant moment today
where we're putting a new monarch into
that circulation so it's quite common
for male Monarch not to wear a crown on
their coinage it happened to his father
his grandfather well they were on
coinage there was no crowd if you're
particularly observant you'll notice
that his majesty is facing the opposite
direction to Queen Elizabeth II on the
coins that we currently use that is in
keeping with tradition when there's a
new monarch the portrait was designed by
sculptor Martin Jennings using photos
and was personally approved by the king
it has to be an image that will persist
over the years and that will represent
the generality of what people imagine
monarchy to be about so it's not just a
portrait of him it's also it needs to
contain the role we'll still have coins
with the Effigy of Queen Elizabeth II
they'll only be replaced once they're
worn or damaged but you won't have to
wait long for these which could start
appearing in your change in December
Becky Cottrell Sky News the Royal Mint